- Les voyageurs terrestres
ont désormais droit
- Je l'ai fait pour moi,
ma mt t t t mon fils.
Par contre, je suis arrivée
et ils ne m'ont rien demandé.
de téléphone "smartphone".
Alors, si s s s s pas avec elle,
elle aurait été pas mal nerveuse
- 25 % à 30 % des voyageurs
ne remplissaient pas
les inr r r r r r r r r r r r r.
Conséquence : de gros
ralentissements aux
frontières terrestres.
Ottawa a donlelelelelelelelelelt
de 14 jours ni d'amende pour
les voyageurs qui oublient
de remplir l'application
ArriveCAN unttttttttttttttttttté
publique fédérale n'a pas
retourné nos demandes
d'entrevue. Mais chez certains
douaniers, on comps.s.s.s.s.s.s.
douanes et de l'immigration
- S'il n'y a pluananananctions
avec l'application ArriveCAN,
on voit mal l'utilité
d'avoir fait ArriveCAN.
en vigueur au plplplplplplplplpx
contrôler le plan de quarantaine
des voyageurs entrant au pays.
DAMIEN CONTANDRIOPOULOS, École
sc. in
- C'est très difficile de voire.
L'idée en santé publique d'avoir
un contrôle emememememememememe,
elle a du sens dans le contexte
à l'intérieur des frontières.
- Et qu'en pensent
les voyageurs? d d d d d d d d ,
je pense que ça ne sert plus
à rien.
- Bien, c'est parce que c'est
pour la pr
des gens, de nous, tu sais.
- C'est mon garçon qui m'a
montré comment faire. Je
traverse régulièrement ici.emem,
mais je trouve que c'est
une perte de temps énorme.
- Malgré ces nouveaux
as
les voyageurs, ce n'est
pas la fin de l'utilis
de l'application ArriveCAN.
Elle est toujours pleinements.s.
Ici Marie Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa